we're in a spending culture America has  a consumerism culture and I joke about  this but the way I like to say it is  traditionally Indian people make a  dollar to spend 20 cents American people  make a dollar to spend two dollars yeah  the help of credit  this is just the culture that we're in  where it's very okay and normalized to  spend money even if you can't afford  something you don't have it and what are  you doing well you're spending all your  money making everybody else around you  rich but you yourself you might look  rich but you're actually broke there's a  reason why the owner and CEO of Louis  Vuitton is the richest person in the  world versus the majority people who  wear Louis Vuitton are broke